football season is here which means that
madden is on the horizon for those of
you thinking this might just be yet
another madden entry
well you're probably right but hey you
know and i know the real reason that we
keep coming back for more every year is
roster updates so hit that like button
as i break down everything to know about
madden 23 if you're interested so you
can see if this might be the madden for
you and spoiler alert there are actually
some decent changes this time around
so let's start with the plot face of the
franchise is the main game mode players
can expect to find something even close
to a traditional plot like in other
video games but it's not usually the
core focus of madden that being said the
premise is basically that you can take
control of a customizable character and
lead a team to the promised land of
winning a coveted super bowl while
cementing your legacy among the greatest
players of all time in the past there
might have been more of a you know
traditional story such as madden 21
where you were competing for the qb spot
with a high school teammate and your
on-field endeavors weaved with the
storyline of your friendly rivalry in
madden 23 from a story perspective not
much has been said other than the story
focusing on players taking their career
to the next level and finding success
after having their contracts team option
expire so what this means rather than
following your player from like the
beginning of their high school or
college career you will start at a time
when they have already earned a few
stripes as a veteran now we're going to
break down what's different about the
gameplay and the game modes madden 23's
biggest change to the core gameplay is
what ea is calling field sense
this is an overhaul to several of the
game's on-field mechanics new tackle
animations and game logic have redressed
the play-by-play nature of the sport
punch out fumbles and more team gang
tackles and tend to bring an extra level
of oomph and aggression to the game
something that ea refers to as the hit
everything feature but it's not just
tackling though every part of the field
is affected by field sense such as
improvements to dbs covering whiteouts
pass rushers collapsing the pocket and
getting to the qbs and of course better
blocking in the trenches now obviously
like with any sports game the players
and you guys in the comments you guys
have the ultimate say on whether field
sense is as sweeping or effective as
it's touted to be
time will tell
me personally i believe that a little
less ultimate team and a lot more
franchise is the golden ticket for
madden to shake off the annual copycat
allegations and when they focus on some
of these radical gameplay changes
sometimes they come off as a little
gimmicky such as last year's dynamic
game day or m factors which gave madden
a kind of sillier sporty version of
basically call of duty kill streaks if
you think about it despite my hesitation
to consider field sense a true game
changer there are a lot of subtleties
about the mechanic that will undoubtedly
flesh themselves out once the game
launches and gets into the player's
hands field sense also brings one of the
more significant changes to your offense
sports fans that have played mlb the
show might catch similarities to the
gameplay as skill-based passing turns
quarterback play into something more
like fielding the ball in the show with
an active throw meter that determines
accuracy this added level of control in
the passing game can help players make
back shoulder catches and hit tight
windows to ea's credit the larger madden
community seems to agree once you get
the hang of it there's no going back so
when it comes to core game modes madden
has many of these core game modes that
are kind of cleverly designed to push
you into ultimate team if we're being
honest but the game modes from past
iterations of madden do make their
return so you'll have head to head and
exhibition matches the aforementioned
face of the franchise mode superstar ko
the yard and the much anticipated fan
favorite franchise mode franchise mode
has been a point of contention in the
past several years with madden fans
pleading for a significant overhaul or
even just a return to the franchise mode
of the earlier madden days that were
full of different features absent and
the more recent madden iterations now
some good news is that this year's game
will improve certain features like the
scouting system and make for a more
frantic free agency period the biggest
takeaways include that your scouting
reports during a season will reveal more
relevant information for each player for
example instead of unlocking a qb's
break tackle attribute you are more
likely to learn something like throw
power or short accuracy and there are
more factors than money to consider in
free agency now players will of course
still get their payday but they'll have
other factors to juggle like the team's
roster depth the quality of the
quarterback or even if your team is in
an income tax-free state
all of this now impacts a free agent's
decision which is kind of cool free
agency bids are also revised so you
won't know if you're in the front of the
pack for a player which in past years
would let you repeatedly tweak an offer
until you suddenly saw your team
leapfrog other offers in the free agency
menu now this change should make the
system a lot more fair to both rival cpu
or human players now let's talk live
service and trust me i know most of us
are not mad and ultimate team or mutt as
we call it fans but this wouldn't be a
proper everything to know if we didn't
address the changes to mutt and in mutt
we've now got the field pass which
provides a clear path to progression
letting you know what you need to do
next
basically a battle pass you can see the
levels rewards and a bunch of objectives
to completely let you make progress on
every field pass i say every cause there
will be multiple live service style
seasons starting off with season one
there will be multiple field passes with
the three primary types season
competitive and ultimate team program
specific passes ea says that you can
earn these rewards with no additional
cost to access the field pass but i'm
not sure if that excludes certain types
of field passes starting with seasonal
this field pass has 60 levels of rewards
ranging from coins packs uniforms and a
high overall player item there won't be
infinitely repeatable objectives but ea
will add more periodically season 1 is
estimated to run for about 60 days
competitive pass will be available at
launch and includes objectives for the
comp modes like solo battles
head-to-head season squad seasons or
mutt champions rewards include the coins
and packs which are usable in mutt and
the comp pass will refresh twice a month
while solo battles and mutt champions
will reset weekly throughout the year
there will be program specific field
passes available
one of the launch programs called
headliners will introduce the first
program specific field pass having its
own rewards and objectives related to
the program comp in program specific
passes will let you double dip with
progress as both of them will contribute
towards your seasonal field pass
multiplayer naturally is a core part of
madden every mode in the game except for
face of the franchise incorporates
multiplayer easily by letting you play
on the couch or online with or against
other players it is the bread and butter
of madden where players can expect to
spend a significant majority of their
time in the game august is always madden
season and this year's game continues
the recent trend of spreading the
release date out a bit depending on
different variables the global launch
date for all platforms is august 19th
and is coming out for xbox series x and
s ps5 xbox one ps4 and pc however there
are a few ways to play it sooner if you
have an ea play or xbox game pass
ultimate subscription you can access the
game's trials as early as august 16th
you can purchase the pricier all madden
edition if you don't have the
subscriptions if you're playing the
trial you'll have up to 10 hours of
gameplay time with full access the sole
exception being stop gaps and face of
the franchise mode if last year was any
indication pre-orders are live right now
with different editions if you're not
interested in ultimate team or the early
access then the standard edition will be
the one for you and it's more than
enough standard edition will run you
59.99 on last gen consoles and 69.99 for
current gen the all madden edition will
run you a whopping hundred bucks but
comes with a lot of madden points and
player cards for ultimate team and dual
entitlement if that's what you're
looking for we're gonna have a lot of
madden coverage coming this month i'm
working personally on getting a live
stream set up for you guys on day one
but be sure to keep an eye out for mark
delaney's official madden review after
the game launches if you're interested
in franchise mode or you want to play
ultimate team but don't want to spend a
dime let me know based on your comments
i'll get more vids cooking for you cater
to what you guys want to see thanks for
watching
[Music]
you